Hey, Little Boy.
ARCAM is so weak,
I'm about to fall asleep.
It's not their fault, Fatman.
They think they can fight our assassin
squad with their pathetic equipment.
Such fools.
You bastard!
You came…
Spriggan!
Yu Ominae!
Y-Yu!
You bastards.
You want the Ark so badly
you would do this?
Want?
No.
A powerful relic like Noah should be
kept under the United States' watch.
That's why we delivered
this righteous retribution!
Righteous?
Screw you, you bastards.
Don't think you can leave
this mountain in one piece!
Fool!
We're nothing like Hummingbat!
You won't be able to defeat me
with attacks like that!
What's the matter, Spriggan?
Keep running!
A single fragment to the head
and it's instant death!
Little Boy!
You punk!
Don't underestimate me!
Too slow!
You punk!
This feels like…
I got you, Spriggan!
You bastards, those body armors…
That's right, it's Orichalcum like yours!
Don't think that ARCAM has a monopoly
on converting OOPArts into weapons.
As long as we're wearing the same
body armor, there's no way we can lose!
Kill him, Fatman!
Break his neck!
Okay, Little Boy!